we are at the verge of a huge Revolution
which is at the magnitude of Relativity
and quantum mechanics at the beginning
of the 20th century every time that
there is in physics two theories which
are not compatible with one another that
is the beginning of of of the
[Music]
adventure the debate is not only between
scientists and historians or
philosophers the debate is within the
retical physics yes special relativity
even general relativity has been
proven in all kinds of experiments but
the collision between quantum mechanics
and special and general relativity is
just is being as sharper and sharper
every day and physics today theoretical
physics today is still within a great
controversy between these two great
clash between these two theories so here
you have experiments in quantum
mechanics which tell you that if two
particles are being measured at the same
time at different places something
although not information is going
between them faster than the speed of
light at infinite velocity it's not
information but there is something this
is something which goes against special
relativity even general relativity there
is a problem here but there it's much
worse so many in uh um experiments in
quantum mechanics tells you that when
you make a measure you don't affect the
particle in the sense that its future
moments are being affected you affect it
also backwards which means something
really crazy it means that it is not
only that the future is open but but the
past is not fixed at least at the
quantum level we have papers on that we
have experiments which have been proved
recently I I believe I showed such a
paper I presented such a paper in a
conference which you were present so we
are at the verge of a huge reol solution
which is at the magnitude of Relativity
and quantum mechanics at the beginning
of the 20th century there is something
very important about scientists being
humans as Kima says but the Schism is
within theoretical physics itself so
many paradoxes which tell you that this
picture nice picture of four dimensions
and all events being there is far from
being the truth let me just give one
example and then then I'll finish a
single Photon hits a a half silvered
mirror you have two detectors here I
made some money with this one of them is
going to give you a click and the other
is not going to give you a click nothing
nothing nothing in physics can tell you
my grand my scientific grandfather David
bomb was the father of who was the
advisor of Yakir aronov believed in some
hidden variables there are no hidden
variables so here are two events two
possible events in the future which
nothing in the present can tell you
which of them will occur that tells you
that the future in some very profound
way does not exist not only for you and
Kima and me in some profound way it does
not exist and it is being built our
world is being built our universe is
adding an event after event in a way
which is still a mystery to physics but
there is a lot of physics in it so can I
please make I I I want to make a couple
one is a very simple logical point I
hope maybe people can take away from
this this is going back a bit there's
the idea that well this event coexists
with that event right and this event
coexists with that event again Newton's
point of view that there's absolute
simultaneity means you've got all these
events they all happen at exactly the
same time that's what he he means by
coexists and in that case coexistence is
transitive it means if a coexists with B
and B coexists with C then a coexists
with C all right so you can reason
along a chain in special relativity in
general relativity you don't have
absolute simultaneity you have the past
of an event you have the future and you
have this whole region outside the light
cone that's called its space likee
separation but that relation of being at
space-like separation is not transitive
a can be at space-like separation from b
b can be at space-like separation from C
but a is not at space like separation
from C so a lot of everyday reasoning
about
coexistence goes through it doesn't go
through anymore in relativity if the
only thing you have to mean by
coexistence is its Bas like separation
so you can get very confused about that
the other point is OB just asserted
there are no hidden variables I have no
idea how he knows that David B's own
Theory will give you all the standard
predictions of non-relative isic quantum
mechanics furthermore the fundamental
equations are only solved forward in
time you don't solve them backwards now
there's other ideas that you can do it
both forward and backward at the same
time but that theory exists he knows it
exists he knows it makes all the same
predictions as standard quantum
mechanics so I I've no idea how he can
say with such certainty there are no
such things go ahead you you follow off
on that point well I I just want want to
again sort of try to clarify I don't
think that that abalam said that hidden
variables don't exist he said that they
haven't been found yet I thought he said
they didn't exist is what I heard well
this is well if it was objective time
this is at the mystery of
if there are hidden variables it they
should remain hidden forever otherwise
yeah otherwise a special relativity
would be violated so if there is
something which remains hidden forever
it's metaphysics it's it belongs more to
religion than to science so I'd like to
come to that moment Mishu I'm I'm aware
that you want to make a point but please
um be mindful of the fact that we've
gone down a very technical rabbit hole
right now um so is is your point going
to be another technical rebuttal Dare I
ask no I'm going to try to simplify the
rabbit hole okay I teach physics I teach
both relativity and quantum mechanics so
for those of you who are confused in the
audience there is no scientific debate
about special relativity that's why we
know why the sun shines that's why we
have hydrogen bonds also quantum
mechanics is well established that's why
we have computers this conversation this
conversation is possible because of the
quantum theory the problem occurs when
we try to unify the two or we try to
create analogies to explain the
mysteries of quantum mechanics and
relativity that's where the debate comes
into the picture because one possibility
is a Multiverse but then that raises
philosophical questions I mean do we
exist with carbon copies of ourselves
someplace else in another part of the
universe how can we have a Multiverse
when you think of yourself as being one
object so that's where the debate occurs
the debate occurs when you start to UNIF
the picture given to us by relativity
and by the quantum theory and then you
get then you get into these paradoxes
but special relativity by itself and
relativity by itself are very well
established almost no scientific deay
whatsoever so I was I was going to try
and sort of steer us towards as we reach
the absolute end in time of our debate
um towards the sort of question about
whether or not these things can be
reconciled or not but I'm really getting
the feeling here that if we can't get to
a consensus it's not going to be POS on
what the problems even are let alone if
they exist um a resolution is
challenging so actually I want to I want
to step back even further right now and
ask the
question why do we care about this right
like in the genuine sense that we have
this feeling of of what time is and then
there's whatever all the theories of
physics do or don't say about reality so
should we care does it even matter
whether or not there is an absolute time
or not because my experience of time is
my experience of time
surely well here it is Professor Kaku
says that the problems emerge only when
you try to integrate Quantom mechanics
with relativity Theory so what is he
saying do not try to integrate them this
is what is so beautiful in science that
you integrate different perspectives I
mean would you have you said that to the
Young Einstein relativity Theory would
never emerge because you would say to
Einstein you have a problem you have
electromagnetism on the one side you
have Galilean in variant on the other on
the other side and you have a problem
when you try to integrate them don't
integrate them Einstein go home and and
there will be no theory of relativity
the problem The Clash the contradiction
between quantum mechanics and relativity
special and general is as acute and as
sharp as the uh the cont contradiction
between Galilean invariance and
electromagnetism every time that there
is in physics two theories which are not
compatible with one another that is the
beginning of of of the adventure you
understand that there is a deeper Theory
which Lies Beneath them and let me tell
you I don't know what the theory will be
but here is my bet and I can assure you
and Tim and K will agree with me and
meet you too the moment we see that
theory we shall all say wow so simple
how didn't I think about it before there
is something about these revolutions
that is so beautiful so simple Professor
Kaku talks a lot about the beauty in the
laws of physics I don't think that the
Multiverse is very beautiful okay well
we're not here to make we're not here to
make personal comments about people's
theories in physics um things that only
scientists do amongst themselves Tim to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas